[موسيقى]
بتوقيت جرينتش الحاديه عشره بتوقيت الرياض
انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
بين بلينكن لقاء عابر وثلاث نقاط واشنطن
ترسل رساله من الهند الى بوتين مفادها
سندعم اوكرانيا
احزاب المعارضه التركيه تتوافق على مرشح
مشترك للرئاسه كمال كلشدار الاسم الاكثر
ترددا والاعلان الاثنين المقبل
العربيه تكشف دورا نساء داعش بمخيم الهول
في تنسيق عمليات القتل والتعذيب لالزام
القاطنين فيه بحكم التنظيم
مجلس نواب الامريكي يوافقوا على مشروع
قانون لرفع السريه عن اصل فيروس كورونا
[موسيقى]
اسعدتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
التي نبداها من نيودلهي هو لقاء من عشر
دقائق فقط لكنه الابرز ربما بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا منذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا الحديث هنا عن اللقاء الذي جمع
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
على هامش اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه مجموعه
العشرين في نيودلهي مسؤولون امريكيون
كشفوا ان الوزيرين تجاذبا اطراف الحديث
لما يقرب من عشر دقائق فقط
[موسيقى]
اليوم تتباطا روسيا مره اخرى في تصدير
المواد الغذائيه من اوكرانيا ومع انتهاء
الصلاحيه مبادره البحر الاسود رفضت روسيا
الالتزام بتجريدها والرساله التي قالتها
الدول في اجتماع اليوم واضحه لابد من
تمديد مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود وتعزيزا
دون تاخير
اخبرت وزير الخارجيه بما قلته الاسبوع
الماضي في الامم المتحده وبما قاله الكثير
من وزراء خارجيه مجموعه العشرين اليوم قلت
له انه حرب العدوان وانخرطوا في دبلوماسيه
هادفه يمكنها انتاج سلام عادل ودائم
ولحد الان لم يصدر اي توضيح رسمي الامريكي
عن فحوى هذا اللقاء المصغر غير ان مسؤولين
امريكيين بارزين اكدوا ان بلينكن انتهز
الفرصه لتوضيح ثلاث نقاط وهي ان الولايات
المتحده ستدعم اوكرانيا في الصراع مهما
استغرقت الحرب وان روسيا عليها التراجع عن
قرارها بتعليق انسحابها من معاهده النوويه
الجديده فضلا عن ضروره افراج روسيا عن
الامريكي بولويلان المحتجز لديها
طلبت روسيا بالتراجع عن قرارها غير
المسؤول والعوده الى تنفيذ معاهده ستارت
الجديده التي تضع قيودا يمكن التحقق منها
على الترسانات النوويه للولايات المتحده
وروسيا على الطرف الاخر فان روسيا تحدثت
عن هذا اللقاء دون ان تليه اهميه كبيره
حيث قللت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه من اهميه
هذا الحديث عن اللقاء وقائله ان كنت تحدثا
بشكل عابر لكنهما لم يعقد مفاوضات او
اجتماع
اكد نائب وزير خارجيه روسيا ان مساعده
الولايات المتحده والدول النوويه مثل
فرنسا والمملكه المتحده يتعارض مع المبادئ
الاساسيه في معاهده ستارت
هذا هو الحال في الظروف الحاليه وذلك
عندما حددت الولايات المتحده والدول
الغربيه الاخرى بما فيها الدول النوويه
مثل فرنسا والمملكه المتحده مسارها بهدف
هزيمه روسيا استراتيجيا في حرب شامله ضدنا
وهو ما يتعارض مع المبادئ الاساسيه
والمفاهيم السياسيه العامه المنصوص عليها
في معاهده ستارت الجديده وفي ظل هذه
الظروف الحاليه اضطررنا الى اعلان تعليق
المعاهده
[موسيقى]
يبدو بان الصراع في اوكرانيا بدا ياخذ
اشكالا مختلفه بعيدا عن القتال المتواصل
بين مقاتلي الجيشين فالهجمات لم تعد تقتصر
على المجموعه العسكريه او القتاليه
المنظمه بل باتت تتم عن طريق مجموعات
تخريبيه حسب الادعاءات الروسيه هذا ما
اعلن عنه حاكم مقاطعه بيرياس الكسندر
بوجماز الذي قال ان مجموعه تخريبيه
اوكرانيه على حد قوله قامت بالتسلل الى
منطقه في مقاطعه بيريانتس على الحدود
الروسيه الاوكرانيه اضاف المسؤول الروسي
ان تلك المجموعه نفذت عمليات الاجراميه
وارهابيه في المنطقه مخلفه قتلى وجرحى
اصيل التي سندها المسؤول فان العمليه تمت
بشكل مخطط باحكام فالمجموعه التخريبيه على
حد قوله تسللت من الحدود الاوكرانيه الى
قريه لوبيتشان الروسيه وقامت بعدها باطلاق
النار على السيارات من تلك المنطقه مما
ادى الى مقتل شخص واصابه طفل يبلغ من
العمر 10 سنوات بجروح كما قامت المجموعه
باحتجاز سته مواطنين كرهائن في مقاطعه
بريال
هذا الهجوم ليضاف الى سلسله من الهجمات
الاوكرانيه التي باتت تستهدف العمق الروسي
مؤخرا حيث كانت القوات الاوكرانيه قد شنت
هجوما على مقاطعه بواسطه مسيره تم اسقاطها
ما ادى الى اشتعال النيران في مبنى سكني
في قريه سوشاني كذلك تعرضت قريه لوما
كوفكا في منطقه ستار دوبسكي لقصف اوكراني
بقذائف الهاون ولم تسجل اصابات لكن تم
تسجيل اضرار في المباني كما كان حاكم
منطقه كورسك رومان ستروفويت قد قال او
افاد بقصف القوات الاوكرانيه لقريه تتكينو
ما اسفر عن وقوع ضحايا
اعلن جهاز الامن الفيدراليه الروسيه انه
طرد القوه الاوكرانيه التي هاجمت برياسك
الى داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه واضاف الجهاد
الامني الروسي انه تجنب مواجهه
الاوكرانيين على اراضي روسيا للحفاظ على
ارواح المدنيين مشيرا الى انه بدا قصفا
مدفعيا عن المجموعه الاوكرانيه في موقع
وجودهم بعد طردهم
نتابع مع مراسلنا في موسكو عبد الجواد
الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا هل تكشفت
كل ملابسات ما حدث في بريانسك من هذا
الاقتحام للمجموعه الاوكرانيه الى داخل
المنطقه الروسيه
في الحرب على روسيا طبعا
وتحدث ايضا بانه سيعتبر كل الدول التي
ستشارك في خدمه هذه الطائرات وهذه
المقاتلات بالاهداف الروسيه هذا طبعا صهيب
يعني هو اشاره عن رؤيه موسكو وثقتها بان
الغرب سيقوم بتزويد الجانب الاوكراني
بالطائرات والمقاتلات في المستقبل القريب
طبعا قضيه بريانس صهيب ليست هي جديده طبعا
هذه المنطقه الحدوديه تتعرض لضربات منذ
بدايه الصراع طبعا كل المناطق على الشريط
الحدودي سقطت فيها العديد من القذائف
دخلتها الطائرات من دون طيار الدرون ايضا
طبعا العديد من الصواريخ سقطت في تلك
المناطق وعلى تلك المدن لكن الجديد في
الموضوع هو عمليه التسلل بصراحه صهيب لا
يمكن اخفاء قلق الحكومه الروسيه من هذا
الموضوع لكنها طبعا لا ترى في هذا الشيء
ازمه كبيره بحيث تحدثت الخارجيه بانه على
موسكو الاستعداد لمواجهه الاسواق وقد يكون
هذا في القريب العاجل صهيب اللافت كذلك
اليوم اللقاء الاول بين وزيري خارجيه
امريكا وروسيا على هامش اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه مجموعه العشرين في نيودلهي في
الهند يبدو ان موسكو لا لم تعر انتباها
كبيرا او لم تعطي اهميه كبيره لهذا اللقاء
عبد الجواد اليس كذلك
نعم صهيب يعني موسكو لا ترى اليوم في ظل
وجود ازمه الثقه الكبيره بينها وبين الغرب
وبين موسكو وواشنطن تحديدا املا في الوصول
الى نقطه حوار هي ترى بان واشنطن تتحكم
بشكل مباشر بقضيه وبالاله العسكريه
الاوكرانيه وتحدث طبعا الخارجيه الروسيه
اليوم بان واشنطن قادر على ايقاف ونهايه
وانهاء هذه الازمه وهذا الصراع العسكري
المسلح في الاراضي الاوكرانيه لذلك طبعا
يعني المواجهه بين وزيري خارجيه روسيا
والولايات المتحده طبعا لم تثمر عن اي شيء
هو لقاء عبر كما شاهد الجميع وكما تابعه
تفاصيله معظم الناس لكن طبعا الوصول الى
حل في ظل الصراع المسلح في ظل ازمه الثقه
الموجوده بشكل غير واضح وهي معدومه حسب
الكثير من القراءات السياسيه الروسيه صعب
في الوقت الحالي لذلك طبعا صهيب قد يحدث
هذا اللقاء في مرات قادمه في مناسبات اخرى
لكن لدى الروس اليوم ثقه كبيره بعدم
الوصول لاتفاق مع الغرب ومع واشنطن تحديدا
عبد الجواد الرشد من موسكو
[موسيقى]
الحرب في اوكرانيا باتت مفتوحه على
احتمالات متعدده فمختلف الاطراف المعنيه
بهذه الحرب بدت تتاهب الى كل السيناريوهات
الممكنه من بين هذه السيناريوهات احتمال
استخدام روسيا للسلاح النوويه التكتيكيه
والذي عاد الى الواجهه مره اخرى بعد تعليق
موسكو العمل رسميا بمعاهده نيو ستارت
النوويه مع الولايات المتحده اتاه بروسيه
لاستخدام السلاح النووي كشفت عنه هذه
المره مجله تابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وتدعى
والتي اكدت ان موسكو تطور استراتيجيه
عسكريه من نوع جديد تستخدم الاسلحه
النوويه لحمايه البلاد من عدوان امريكي
المحتمل على حد قول المجرات الروسيه
وتعد هذه المره الاولى التي يتحدث فيها
تقرير من هذا النوع عن تهديد امريكي مباشر
على روسيا وتقتضي الخطه باستخدام الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه الهجوميه والدفاعيه الحديثه
والاسلحه النوويه وغير النوويه مع الاخذ
في الحسبان احدث التقنيات العسكريه ولا
ترغب موسكو في تهيئه نفسها فقط لان الهجوم
محتمل على اراضيها بل ايضا توجيهي رسائل
للولايات المتحده تؤكد فيها استعدادها
لاسوء السيناريوهات وذهب المسؤولون
والساسه الروس على الادلاء بتصريحات تلمح
لامكانيه استخدام السلاح النووي مشيرين
الى ان موسكو ستكون مستعده اذا لزم الامر
لنشري ترسنتها النوويه الضخمه
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى تركيا حيث اعلنت احزاب المعارضه
التصميم مرشح لخوض انتخابات الرئاسه ضد
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وقالت المعارضه
انها ستعلن اسم المرشح يوم الاثنين المقبل
فيما افادت وسائل الاعلام التركيه انه تم
التوافق على اسم زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري
كمال من قبل خمسه احزاب الا ان زعيمه حزب
الخير ميرال اكشنار اقترحت اسمها عمده
اسطنبول اكرم الماموغلو وطلبت بعد ذلك
العوده الى التشاور مع حزبها
معنا من انقره بركات قرار المحلل السياسي
البركات اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
من من الاسماء في المعارضه التركيه الاوفر
حظا
كي يكون ممثلا للمعارضه في هذه الانتخابات
التركيه المقبله
مساء الخير اولا مساء الحقيقه يعني ليس
جديده
والمراقبون والراي العام كل احد يعرف بانه
المرشح الان بين الاحزاب المعارضه هو
كمال كلش دارو له اليوم الوثيقه التي
اعلنت على اساس من قبل الاحزاب الست بانه
اتفقنا على المرشح المشترك وعلى مسار
خارطه الطريق
للتغيير يعني هذه النقطتين كانت مهمه طبعا
وهم ليست كمان
خفيا عن بالنسبه
للخلافات اللي كانت بينهم وخاصه بين حزب
الشعب
جمهوري وحزب الجيد حزب الجيد كما نعرف
والجميع بانه حزب يميني متطرف
يعني هو الاوفر حقا بين الاحزاب السته او
ما يعرف بتحالف الامه ومصطلح عليه بتسميته
بالطاوله السداسيه من سته احزاب هذا
التحالف اليوم في هذه الانتخابات بعد
الزلزال المدمر في تركيا الى اي حد هو قوي
امام العداله والتنميه والرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان
عزيزي الكريم
تقف هذه الامر
لموقف هذه الاحزاب الست من حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي يعني الان بان هم اوفر حظا
بالحقيقه هذه المعارضه للنجاح وهزيمه طيب
اردوغان في الانتخابات القادمه وحتى في
هذه الظرف بالتداعيات
الزلزال
ايضا كانت لصالح المعارضه لانه
السلطات للاسف الشديد يعني كان تقصيره
واضح ومعروف من قبل كل
الجماهير والمنظمات والاحزاب في تركيا لكن
بتعلق الامر ايضا في موقف الاحزاب الست
عندما يتفقوا اتفقوا مثلا على قله او غيره
لا يكفي هذا الان لان يهزمون طيب اردو اذا
لم يقومون بتنسيق مع حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي وحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي هو لا
يهم الشخصيه بحد ذاتها بقدر ما يهمه
المبادئ والبرنامج التي سيعلن حول التغيير
وحول التطورات وحول الحقوق الديمقراطيه في
البلد لانه هناك والقضاء وكل ما عالق يعني
والاقتصاد وغيره يعني الحزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي كما تعرفون بانه هو ضمن تحالف
العمل والحريه ايضا ويشكلون يعني ما يقارب
حوالي 15% من الاصوات هذا هو المفتاح
الاساسي بالحقيقه في هذه الانتخابات
بالتاكيد حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي لم يكن
ولم يتفق مع حزب العداله والتنميه اطلاقا
لكن محتمل ان يعلن بالحقيقه مرشح في
المرحله الاولى اذا
اذا لم
الاحزاب الست يتجهون وان السقون معه شكرا
في هذه المسار شكرا جزيلا لكم بركه قار
مباشره من انقره
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بلومبرج تقول
ان اسرائيل قد تضرب ايران قبل حصولها على
اس 400 التفاصيل بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديدة تحديد النوويه
الايرانيه يستنفرو اسرائيل التي قد تسرع
في توجيه ضربه الى طهران فالتطورات
الاخيره التي طفت على السطح قد تدفع تل
ابيب الى تنفيذ هجوم على طهران سيما وان
الاخيره تفكر في الحصول على انظمه دفاع
جوي الخبر كشفت عنه وكاله بلومبرج التي
ذكرت ان ايران تسعى للحصول على منظومه
الدفاع الجوي الروسيه اس 400 خطوه قد تؤدي
الى تسريع خططي تل ابيب في توجيه ضربه
محتمله لبرنامج طهران النووي فحصول طهران
على هذه الانظمه سيسمح لها بالتصدي
للهجمات الصاروخيه وهو ما يدفع اسرائيل
الى التعجيل في تنفيذ ضربتها
وحصول ايران على انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه لم يتم تاكيدها كما كان متوقعا في
روسيا لم تصرح بشكل علني اذا ما كانت
ستزود ايران بالاسلحه رغم الاتهامات
الغربيه المستمره لها بالتعاون العسكري مع
طهران وتاتي كل هذه التطورات في وقت يزداد
فيه القلق بشان الخطوات النوويه الايرانيه
منذ ان عثر مراقبون وكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه على يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه 84% وهي
نسبه اقل بقليل من 90% اللازمه لتصنيع
السلاح النووي
ولطالما اعربت اسرائيل عن خشيتها من تمكن
ايران من الحصول على اسلحه نوويه ما جعلها
تلوح مرارا بامكانيه تنفيذ هجوم على طهران
وكان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو قد
اكد بهذا الخصوص انه كلما طال الانتظار
كلما اصبح الامر اكثر صعوبه واضاف نتنياهو
بان تل ابيب انتظرت طويلا مضيفا انه سيفعل
كل ما بوسعه لمنع ايران من الحصول على
اسلحه نوويه
هذا هو من المتوقع ان يصل وزير الدفاع الى
الامريكي الى اسرائيل يوم الاربعاء المقبل
في زياره تستغرق يومين وفق ما نقله موقع
اكسيوس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين وقال مسؤول
امريكي ان زياره اوستن تهدف الى الاشاره
لدعم الولايات المتحده لوزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي
الذي تعتبره اداره بايدن محاورا موثوقا
يمكن للولايات المتحده العمل معه كما اخبر
مسؤولين امريكيان موقع اكسيوس ان الاداره
الامريكيه تريد العمل مع نتنياهو لمواجهه
ايران
معنى من واشنطن مايكل كبير والباحثين في
معهد هاتسون مايكل اهلا بك معنا في اخبار
الساعه من العربيه كل مره يكون هناك حديث
عن احتماليه توجيه ضربه عسكريه من قبل
اسرائيل لايران ولكن تكون العقبه الضوء
الاخضر الاميركي لهذه الضربه العسكريه هل
برايك في هذه المرحله
واشنطن ستعطي الضوء الاخضر لاسرائيل كي
توجه ضربه عسكريه لايران
شكرا لكم على الاستضافه اعتقد ان اسرائيل
سوف تنفذ الضربه بغض النظر عن ضوء الاخضر
الامريكي طبعا الولايات المتحده يجب ان
توافق على الهجوم
يركز على النووي في الوقت الذي تسعى ايران
للحصول على القنبله النوويه واذا اختارت
اداره بايدن ان تصمت فهذه اشاره خضراء لكن
اذا ما قالت الاداره الامريكيه لا يجب على
اسرائيل
تهاجم واذا مهاجمت فهذا يتطلب دعما في
الكونجرس الامريكي
نعم طيب ما حجم الضربه الان مع الحديث على
العصور الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه على
يورانيوم مخصب يقترب من 90% في احدى
المنشات الايرانيه
برايك هل اسرائيل يعني من خلال هذه الضربه
المتوقعه
ستجر المنطقه الى الى مواجهه كبيره برايك
ام لا ستكون
الضربه محدوده دعنا نقول
اعتقد ان الهجوم سيكون عباره عن ضربه جويه
جراحيه
والضد المواقع النوويه الايراني قد يتعلق
الامر باستخدام صواريخ كروز ايضا
والاسرائيليون لديهم القدرات دعنا نتحدث
عن الرد اذا قامت اسرائيل بهذه الضربه
نتوقع من الجهه الاسلامي ان يطلق سواريخ
وكذلك حماس بالنسبه لحزب الله نحن متاكدين
لان
الحزب ينظر الى ايران من زاويه مختلفه
العقوبات
الامريكي وبالتالي فحزب الله تبنى تفكير
استراتيجي لكن الجهاد الاسلامي وحماس
والمليشيات العراقيه قد تكون مستعدا
لتنفيذه هجمات صاروخيه في اسرائيل
واسرائيل لديها القبه الحديديه اما الرد
من ايران تحديدا
اسرائيل هذا قد يؤدي بايران الى استهداف
الموقع الامريكيه في العراق او سوريا
والقول بانوات المتحده سمحت بهذا الهجوم
الاسرائيلي ولكن نستطيع ان نقول ان
اسرائيل تستطيع ان تتصرف بحريه ولديها
علاقه مهمه مع روسيا للقيام بهذا اي
مهاجمه ايران وقد قامت اسرائيل بذلك ضد
ايران في سوريا ولم يتحرك بوتين
والصواريخ 400 في سوريا لم تستخدم اطلاقا
ضد الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه والمسرحه بوتين الا تحصل
ايران على القنبله النوويه وروسيا والصين
لا ترغبان في حصول الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
على القنبله النوويه كانت هذه دائما مشكله
قد يوفقان على السعي الى الحصول على
تنازلات وتهديد بصنع القنبله للحصول على
تنازلات من الغرب وهذا يفيد روسيا والصين
وايران
لكن حصول ايران على القنبله النوويه سوف
يؤدي بموافقه الولايات المتحده
وروسيا والصين تغدان الترف اذا ما نفذت
اسرائيل هجوما شكرا جزيلا لك مايكل كنت
معنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
حقبه قوانين تنظيم داعش المتشدده وحكمه
القائم على الترهيب لم ينتهي بعد العربيه
وضمن تغطيتها الخاصه تمكنت من دخول مخيم
روج الذي تقيم فيه عوائل عناصر ومقاتلي
داعش الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
نتفاوض معها للحديث بعد ان تملكها ارتياب
وتردد
قبل سنه فقط كانت كاساندات داعشيه
البلجيكيه وزوجه احد قاده التنظيم
المقتولين في الرقه تتحدث بثقه مع العربيه
عن قصتها كاول امراه تخلع النقاب في مخيم
روج
هيئتها تغيرت وقبضه خلايا التنظيم اشتدت
وان امتنعت عن تفسير تحولها هذا
اخر
مش محجبه غير منقبه بس يعني مختلف من برا
بس من جوا ما غير شيء يعني
ماذا ما
بدي نحكي من هذا
كانت رؤيه الكثيرات يتجولن دون غطاء راس
ممكنه هناك لكن اليوم 30 فقط بقينا دون
حجاب او نقاب ريان واحده منهن تقول انها
تعرضت للتهديد وعرضوا عليها اموالا
كتير كتير
وكمان
يعني هذا الحكي
بعض نسوان قالولي
[موسيقى]
حالي وهذا الشيء بيكفي
من مخيم روج انتقل الى الهول الاخطر على
الاطلاق
المواجهه الامنيه مع تنظيم داعش كانت اكثر
حصما ووضوحا لكن مواجهه فكره وارثه معركه
اخرى لم تحسم بعد هنا في مخيم الهول في
الحسكه نسخه متجدده عن تنظيم داعش اصغر
ولكنها ليست اقل تطرفا فلتنظيم هنا ممولون
خلايا التجنيد والتدريب كما له قوانين
ومحاكم
الحسابات مختلفه هنا وكلها تخضع لقوانين
داعش ترهيب ملا يلتزم بقوانين التنظيم
وحرق خيانهن او ايذاءهن جسديا هذه الصور
كافيه لشرح ما يحدث اربع نساء احتجزهن
التنظيم وقيدهن بالسلاسل في مركز تعذيب
اقيم سرا داخل مخيم الهول
[موسيقى]
لا تتوقف نساء داعش عند التعذيب العام
الماضي شهد المخيم مقتل 36 شخصا بينه
فتاتان مصريتان اكتشفت جثتهما في مجاري
الصرف الصحي حوادث كشفت عن دور المحوري
للنساء داخل خلايا التنظيم بينها تهريب
السلاح
لم يقتصر نشاط نساء داعش داخل حدود مخيم
الهول فالتحقيقات كشفت ايضا انهن حلقه وصل
رئيسيه لتنسيق هجمات التنظيم
في مخيم الهول قصه لا تنتهي هذا قسم
مستحدث يسمونه المنطقه الامنه ينقل اليه
من يثبت ان حياته في خطر بسبب تهديد خلايا
داعش انا
[موسيقى]
جنب مسجد
الثاني ولما يضربوا حدا
رصاص نسمع صوت رصاص مثلا الفجر مشان انها
صفات القارئ
امام المسجد
فيه خلايا داعش وتسع لكسر قيود الاحتجاز
واعاده تنظيم صفوفها ساره بن عيشوباء
العربيه من شمال شرق سوريا
[موسيقى]
اتهمت قائده عمليات الجزيره في قوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه ديلبرين كوباني تركيا بتصليحه
وتدريب عناصر داعش لتنفيذ عمليات في مناطق
الاداره الذاتيه شمال شرق سوريا
طالما لم يتم قطع العلاقات التركيه مع
داعش لن تنتهي تهديدات داعش هذا مؤكد
تقوم الدوله التركيه بتثبيت الداعش في راس
العين بهذه الاسلحه ويستخدمها داعش في
مناطقنا ثم يستخدمون شاحنات لنقل هذه
الاسلحه الى مناطقنا وقد تم اكتشافهم تقوم
تركيا ايضا بتدريب عناصر داعش على
التكتيكات بما ان داعش قد دخلوا حقبه
جديده
وخلال هذه المقابله الخاصه مع العربيه
كشفت قائده عمليات الجزيره في قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه دلبرين كوباني عن اعتقال 170
عنصرا من داعش في مخيم الهول قاموا بتجنيد
عناصر وخططوا لتنفيذ هجمات
اعتقلنا ما يقرب عن 170 عنصرا من داعش
اثناء العمليه في مخيم الهول يرجى التحقيق
معهم حاليا
واحتجزنا معظم هذه العناصر لاننا كنا
نراقب تحركاتهم كانوا مطلوبين وكانوا
يقومون بالتجنيد لداعش فيما خطط عناصر
اخرون من داعش للتحضير لهجماتهم القادمه
[موسيقى]
في لبنان استغلت مؤسسه القرض الحسن
التابعه لحزب الله انهيار القطاع المصرفي
تحولت الى قطاع مصرفيه رديف متخطيتا شروط
قانون النقد والاقراض ومع اقتصار وجود
فروع القرض الحسن خلال الاعوام الماضيه
ضمن مناطق محسوبه على حزب الله اثار انشاء
فرع له في قريه المسيحيه تساؤلات حول
الهدف خلف هذا التوسع
[موسيقى]
ثم ان قريه سوق الغرب المسيحيه تقع بين
قريتين شيعيتين الا ان حزب الله اختارها
احد الشوارعها لبناء فرع جديد للقرض الحسن
هذا اول مبنى يشاهده حزب الله خارج حدودي
بيئته رغم ارتفاع الاصوات المناهضه للدوري
المصرفي الذي يلعبه
رئيس بلديه سوق الغرب التابع للتيار
الوطني الحر اعطى الاذن لتشييد البناء رغم
معرضه النسبه الاكبر من اعضاء البلديه اذا
مع او ضد افتتاح القرض الحسن هون
اما السكان فقليلون منهم وافقوا على
التعليق امام الكاميرا خاصه وانهم على
مرمى حجر من كره تناصر حزب الله 11 بلديه
رفضوا راس البلديه
الجمعيه التي اسست على فرضيه العمل الخيري
قبل اربعين عاما تمددت وتمادت مستفيده من
انهيار القطاع المصرفي
وفيما توقفت المصارف عن تقديم القرود رفعت
الجمعيه عدد اسرعها الى 31 فرعا وقدمت
قرودا بدون فوائد عبر رهن ذهاب وممتلكات
ونشرت ماكينات الصراف الالي ضاربه بقانون
النقد والتسليف عرض الحائط يجب ان يخضع
التسليف لاحكام القانون هذا الشيء ما عمله
ولكن نمط حزب الله ان يحل دائما محل
مؤسسات الحكوميه وان يعطل المؤسسات
الدستوريه هيك عمل باليمن هيك عمل بالعراق
هيك عامل بسوريا هيك عامل بلبنان واليوم
بالسودان
ينطلق اذا بدك من جهاز
خليني اقول مصري في معين
هو بلش في من جمعيه خيريه خلينا نقول
تتوصل مرحله تصير هي بتقود اغلبيه الحركه
الاقتصاديه عند حزب الله يعني للتساؤل
فانا برايي لازم بمعزل عن المسيحيين حتى
عند الشيعه حتى عند السنه حتى عند
المسيحيين
للدوله اللبنانيه لازم الدوله اللبنانيه
هي تاخدها مع الاعتبار لانه بنهايه المطاف
عم بيكون في نظام مصرفي رديف للمصرف لنظام
مصرف اللبناني
ومثل كل مؤسسه حزب الله لبنان المهدد بخفض
تصنيفه الى الرمادي او الاسود يقف عجزا
امام نظام مصري في غير مشروع سيزيد من سوء
سمعته الماليه استفاد حزب الله من انهيار
القطاع المصرفي فبنى مؤسساته على انقاذ
الدوله بعد ان وصف لاعوام بدوله داخل دوله
غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت
[موسيقى]
دانه الامارات تصريحاتي وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليه
التي دعا فيها الى محو بلده حواره
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه اعتبرت وزاره
الخارجيه الاماراتيه في بيان ان تصريحات
الوزير الاسرائيلي عنصريه واكدت الخارجيه
الاماراتيه على رفض كافه الممارسات التي
تتعارض مع القيم والمبادئ الاخلاقيه
والانسانيه وشددت ايضا على ضروره مواجهه
خطاب الكراهيه والعنف
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه هجوم بالرصاص
على متجر تملكه زوجه نجم كره القدم ليونيل
ميسي والعثور على رساله تهديد لميسي داخل
المتجر
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد صفحه فيروس كورونا لم
تطوى بعد حيث عاد الفيروس ليتصدر العناوين
من جديد بعد نشره وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه
اخبارا تفيد بان الفيروس تسرب من احد
المختبرات الصينيه التقرير الامريكي
رافقته مطالب داخليه بالكشف عن كافه
المعلومات التي تخص التحقيقات في منشا
الفيروس وهو ما تمت الاجابه او الاستجابه
اليها على مستوى مجلس النواب الامريكي
الذي اقر بالاجماع مشروع قانون يطالب
الحكومه برفع السريه عن جميع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه حول اصل فيروس كورونا
وتعليقا على هذا القرار اعتبر السيناتور
الجمهوري جورج هاولي الموافقه على المشروع
امرا ايجابيا للغايه فالناس بحاجه الى
معرفه حقيقه ما حصل على حد قوله
نتابع مباشره من واشنطن مع مراسلنا حسين
الطاوود حسين اهلا بك معنا هل هناك من
تفاصيل اضافيه حول ما كشفه تقرير وزاره
الطاقه الامريكيه عن اصل فيروس كورونا
تحيه لك صهيب رسميا البيت الابيض كما ذكرت
المتحدثه باسمه
لا يوجد معلومات كافيه لتحدد الاصل وكذلك
اعلن الوزير الخارجيه بانه لم الولايات
المتحده حتى الان اصل هذا الفيروس ولكن
التشريع الذي تفضلت وتحدثت عنه مشروع
القرار الذي قدم في مجلس الشيوخ من قبل
السيناتور
حظي بموافقه بالاجماع اي انها له الان
تاييد من الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
وياتي وجاء ذلك بعد يوم من تصريحات مدير
الاف بي اي
كريستوفور راي الذي اكد بانه على الارجح
بان اصل فيروس كورونا كان بسبب تفشي من
احد المختبرات في وهران في الصين هذا
التاكيد وهذا التصريح من قبل مدير الاف بي
اي زاد من مطالب الجمهوريين في مجلس
الشيوخ ومجلس النواب للمطالبه بالمزيد من
المعلومات نص المشروع
صهيب يطالب مدير الاستخبارات الامريكيه
الان بتقديم او برفع السريه عن كل
المعلومات التي تشير الى كورونا يعني
وتم رفع السريه عن هذه المعلومات ما الذي
سيتغير
الان حتى نصل الى هذه النقطه يجب ان يمر
هذا المشروع ايضا في مجلس النواب هو في
مجلس الشيوخ كما قلنا بالاجماع يجب ان يمر
بمجلس النواب ومن المرجح ان يمر بمجلس
النواب بسبب اغلبيه الجمهوريين فيه وبسبب
ايضا المطالب الجمهوريه من قبل اللجنه
الفرعيه الخاصه المتعلقه بالتحقيق
بالاستجابه لفيروس كورونا والتي طالبت
الاف بي اي ووزاره الخارجيه ووزاره الطاقه
الامريكيه بالمزيد من المعلومات لكي تكمل
تحقيقاتها بعدما يمر في مجلس النواب فيرسل
الى البيت الابيض ليتم توقيعه ولكن هل
سيوقع عليه من قبل البيت الابيض حتى الان
الاداره الامريكيه تبدو حريصه صهيب حول
توجيه التهم بشكل رسمي هذا من خلال ما
سمعناه من قبل المسؤولين الامريكيين جون
كيربي المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
وانتون بلينك الوزير الخارجيه
ايضا المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض يجب ان
يمر بمجلس النواب يجب ان يوقعه الرئيس
ولكن ليس من المؤكد ان كان سيتم توقيعه
لانه اذا وقع من قبل الرئيس يصبح قانونا
وعندها هناك مده 90 يوما ليتم بالفعل رفع
السريه عن هذه المعلومات الموجوده لدى
وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه شكرا لك حسين طو
مباشره من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
لا طالما حظيت الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه باهميه كبيره حتى قبل اشهر من
موعدها واستطلاعات الراي لا تتوقفوا عن
رصد حظوظ المرشحين وتارجحها لدى الناخبين
اخر هذه الاستطلاعات لا يبدو انها تصب
كثيرا في مصلحه الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن
فوفقا لاستطلاع عن اجرته ياه نيوز
بالتعاون مع شركه يوغوف البريطانيه
للابحاث تبين ان 88% من المسجلين في
الانتخابات يعتقدون ان بايدن البلغ من
العمر 80 عاما كبير جدا بالنسبه لولايه
اخرى ومن بين الناخبين الديمقراطيين وافق
ثمانيه على ان تقدم بايدن في العمر يمثل
مشكله حقيقيه فيما قال 34% انهم لا يدعمون
هذا الراي كما قال غالبيه
المستقلين وتبلغ نسبتهم 71% ان سن 82 كبير
جدا على ان يبدا به بايدن فتره ولايه
ثانيه كرئيس لامريكا
[موسيقى]
ذكر رئيس بلديه روزاريو الارجنتينيه
الشخصين على مسجد دراجه الناريه اطلق
النار في اتجاه متجر تملكه عائله انتونيلا
روكوزو زوجه نجم كره القدم ليونيل ميسي
وترك الشخصان رساله تهديد موجهه لميسي
ومكتوب فيها نحن في انتظارك لن ينفعك
بابلو خافكين في اشاره لرئيس البلديه
واظهرت لقطات تلفزيونيه مضاريفها رصاص
فارغه على الرصيف حيث يقع متجر زوجه ميسي
[موسيقى]
قد تبدو فكره امتلاك البشر لاجنحه او
مخالب او ذراع اضافيه امرا خياليا الى حد
ما لكن هذه السيناريوهات يمكن ان تصبح
حقيقه في العقود القليله المقبله وذلك
بفضل الاطراف البشريه فقد نجح الباحثون
بالفعل في اضافه ابهام ثالث ليد بشريه يتم
التحكم بها باستخدام مستشعرات الضغط
المتصله باقدامهم ونقلا عن خبراء تحدثوا
لصحيفه ديلي ميل البريطانيه فان اضافه
الابهام هي مجرد خطوه اولى نحو اضافات
اكبر واكثر لجسم الانسان
وتجربه اضافه ابهام سادس اذن فتحت نافذه
امام امكانيه اضافه اطراف اخرى بهذا
الخصوص قالت تمرمكين وهي استاذه علم
الاعصاب الادراكيه في جامعه كامبريدج ان
قدره الدماغ على التكيف مع طرف اضافي كانت
غير عاديه وعندما سئلت عما اذا كان من
الممكن تصميم اجنحه او حتى مخالب للانسان
والاستخدام البشري قالت البروفيسور ماكين
ان الامر ممكن من منظور تقنيات موجوده
وهناك حاجه فقط الى توسيع نطاقها
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا ابتداء من الغد وفي تغطيه
خاصه تبدا من العاشره صباحا بتوقيت
السعوديه السابعه بتوقيت غرينتش تحتفل
العربيه بالذكرى العشرين لانطلاقتها في
الثالث من مارس عام 2003 باقه متنوعه من
النشرات ستتابعونها معنا غدا مشاهدينا
اذا بهذا مشاهدينا نتمنى لكم يعني عام
سعيد للعربيه ولكم ايضا انتم اعزائي
المشاهدين تابعونا غدا اذا في هذه التغطيه
الخاصه في ذكرى العربيه العشريه كلوا معنا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]